[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 7 janvier bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 60 18
26 minutes d'actualité locale
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition la visite de jean baptiste
djebbari à toussus-le-noble le
secrétaire d'état aux transports et tête
hier sur le site de l'aérodrome
découverte sur place des nouvelles
technologies de l'aéronautique propre et
dont l'avion électrique alpha électro la
première job academy avec le département
des yvelines bientôt terminée cette
action de retour à l'emploi est proposée
par fassiez bling nous avons suivi une
fiole pendant plusieurs étapes de son
parcours
et puis la page dédiée aux élections
municipales à la fin ce journal à
guyancourt l'union des démocrates
musulmans français a investi un candidat
ma belle à des qte qui se présente pour
la première fois au scrutin
mais avant de commencer cinq ans jour
pour jour qui a été perpétré l'attentât
tôt l'attentât contre charlie hebdo et
douze victimes assassinées dont huit
membres de la rédaction et deux
policiers
le 7 janvier 2015 date du début de cette
folie meurtrière qui durera trois jours
et qui causera la mort d'une autre
policière ainsi que de quatre personnes
lors de l'attaqué contre l'hyper cacher
à paris contre la barbarie souvenez-vous
de nombreuses hommage s'étaient
déroulées dans les yvelines est
notamment à rambouillet le dimanche 11
janvier 2015 dix mille personnes ont
participé à une marche dans la ville du
sud yvelines dans le cortège des
pancartes je suis charlie et de nombreux
drapeaux français
je vous le disais dans les titres le
secrétaire d'état aux transports jean
baptiste djebbari s'est rendu à
l'aérodrome de toussus le noble ce lundi
l'occasion de dresser un bilan de
l'avion électrique en fonctionnement
depuis un an sur le site et de découvrir
les moteurs propres de demain marylène
iapichino et patrick jacques de dixmude
valoriser les innovations aéronautique
compatible avec les engagements
écologiques et environnementaux pris par
le gouvernement notamment lors de la cop
c'était l'objectif du secrétaire d'état
des transports en visite à toussus le
noble
il a lui même essayé cet avion
électrique alpha électro plus propre et
surtout moins bruyant destinés à la
formation des pilotes en service depuis
presque un an
nous avons un avion qui vole et le fait
que le ministre vienne c'est un facteur
supplémentaire pour faire comprendre à
l'ensemble des parties prenantes que où
on est sur une solution de transition
énergétique avec un avion volant avec de
l'énergie électrique
la visite s'est poursuivie avec la
présentation de la start-up turbo tech
qui présente son avancement dans la
construction de moteurs propres
l'entreprise une dizaine de salariés
vise une centaine d'embauchés à
l'horizon 2025 dans l'aéronautique il ya
beaucoup de concurrence surtout dans les
nouvelles technologies dans la
propulsion électrique turbo tech
actuellement une longueur d'avancé et
donc la france a une longueur d'avancé
qu'on aimerait c'est allé très vite pour
pouvoir justement garder sept longueurs
d'avancé et des premiers à proposer des
solutions réellement utilisable de
propulsion hybride pour l'aéronautique
ce qui est le cas actuellement
et c'est donc au travers des discussions
que j'ai eues ici la conviction que nous
serons
inventé en france un modèle qui
réconciliera à la fois l'écologie
l'industrie les territoires et le
progrès ce qui dans les temps que nous
connaissons actuellement me paraissent
tout à fait à propos des avions dont la
pollution environnementale et sonores
sont diminués des innovations
développées à toussus le noble dont
l'objectif est donc aussi de rayonner à
l'international
le secrétaire d'état qui a été bien sûr
questionné sur la grève actuelle contre
la réforme des retraites 34e jour de
mouvement
alors que les négociations ont repris
aujourd'hui entre le gouvernement et les
syndicats une mobilisation qui perturbe
encore le trafic dans les transports le
dépôt des cars fait bus à versailles a
été une nouvelle fois bloqué ce matin du
côté des rails vos prévisions de
circulation pour la journée de demain
mercredi sur la ligne u compte et un
train toutes les trente minutes aux
heures de pointe c'est un train par
heure aux heures creuses pas de
circulation après 20h15 pour la ligne e
n des trains circuleront toute la
journée il y aura un train toutes les 15
minutes à deux heures trente sur l'ex
paris montparnasse rambouillet aux
heures indiquées
c'est à peu près la même chose sur la kz
plaisir grignon et pour les lignes de
rer quelques changements attention plus
train après 19h30 sur le rer a et b côté
ya un train sur deux aux heures de
pointe et un train sur un train toutes
les trente minutes pardon sur la branche
yvelines c'est un train sur deux aux
heures de pointe sur le rer b un train
sur trois aux heures creuses
enfin pour le rer c comptez 1 train sur
3 conséquence sans doute du blocage de
sept des huit raffineries françaises et
aussi de l'afflux des automobilistes
pour faire le plein d'essence quelques
stations-service des yvelines se
retrouvent en rupture partielle voire
totale de carburant selon la carte que
vous voyez à la carte participative mon
essence point fr et de stations serait à
sec à saint quentin en yvelines à 17h
moins de 5 ans rupture partielle le
blocage des raffineries est prévu
jusqu'à vendredi au moins le
gouvernement et acteurs du secteur ne
parle pas encore de pénurie accompagner
les demandeurs d'emploi par des employés
d'entreprises du territoire c'est
l'objectif de la job academy proposé par
la fondation agir contre l'exclusion une
nouvelle édition se tient jusqu'au 31
janvier avec le conseil départemental
des yvelines
la première édition avec cette
collectivité aurelio et mélanie poker
ont suivi
l'une des filles lors de plusieurs
ateliers regarder à deux fois par mois
depuis le mois d'octobre
anne charlotte et sandrine se
rencontrent entre ma reine et fille anne
charlotte est demandeuse d'emploi mère
de quatre enfants elle cherche à
reprendre son parcours professionnel
c'est plus un projet professionnel en
fait que je viens chercher parce que je
suis un peu perdue devant l'étendue et
puis peut-être pas très sûr de moi étant
donné que j'ai pas trahi pendant
quelques années j'ai une formation
juridique donc ça pourrait être le
juridique mais
et voilà je suis ouverte à beaucoup de
choses aussi sandrine et salariés des
yvelines comme 11 autres membres de la
structure elle s'est portée volontaire
pour participer à une job academy
une première pour l'établissement
départemental je suis assez intéressé
par l'accompagnement les questions liées
à l'emploi m'intéresse et puis chez ge
et la curiosité de l'autre et je trouve
qu'on se nourrit aussi beaucoup de
l'expérience de l'autre et ils sont
vraiment ils surfent 1 de l'ensemble de
nos directions nous avons des
travailleurs sociaux des personnes de la
rh des systèmes d'information nous avons
même des personnes de la direction
générale des services donc voilà un
large panel de nos métiers la job
academy ce sont aussi des ateliers en
groupe 4 mois des changes
professionnelle initiée par face
yvelines la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion
comment on arrive chacun d'entre nous à
surmonter une épreuve parce que il ya
toujours un moment dans la vie où on
manque de confiance en soi partage de
moments difficiles ou d'espoirs lors de
la recherche d'un emploi un moyen de
trouver des clés techniques et morales
est ce qu'on appelle nous aller vers une
meilleure employabilité
c'est ce qu'il va donner cette impulsion
par un accompagnement qui est
personnalisé mais qui surtout fait dans
le cadre de l'entreprise atelier des
changes mais aussi ateliers pratiques ce
matin la simulation d'entretien est
faite par un membre des ressources
humaines et une marraine anne charlotte
postule à une offre d'emploi de juristes
des droits des affaires on a
l'impression passer un vrai entretient
donc c'est bien c'est un bon ça booste
et ça ça aide à se préparer ça motive et
puis elles m'ont donné aussi plein de
petits trucs elles m'ont dit aussi ce
qui n'allait pas et sur lequel il
fallait travailler un peu donc non c
très constructif dans quelques jours
anne charlotte retrouvera sa marraine
pour finaliser son projet professionnel
la job academy se termine le 31 janvier
sur les douze filles l'accompagné six
ont déjà trouvé un emploi en ce mois de
janvier les maires de l'agglomération
ont commencé leur cérémonie de voeux à
la population
hier soir lundi c'est bertrand ou lyon
qui a présenté les siens magny les
hameaux l'occasion pour le maire
génération de tirer un bilan de l'année
2019 est la fin des travaux de la plaine
de cheveux courts ou encore le futur de
deux fermes présente sur la ville celle
de gomberville qui a été acquise par
saint quentin en yvelines
la ferme de bel hoyé ne sera finalement
pas vendu résultat d'une agglo mais à
d'une réunion organisée en décembre avec
l'agglomération et les précisions du
maire au micro de mélanie poquet
l'objectif de travail sur un projet qui
soit à vocation agricole à vocation donc
locale d'insertion de formation et
tourisme c'était le combat qu'on a mené
pendant toute l'année précédente voir
les années précédentes encore puisque
cette ferme n'est plus utilisé depuis
2015 on souhaite absolument
la partie agricole de cette ferme puisse
retrouver sa vocation
on a des serres on a des seins des
espaces en plein champ qui était
magnifique qui sont aujourd'hui
déplorable c'est l'un des premiers temps
forts du sport saint quentinois en ce
début d'année l'open de tennis de la
dernière débute samedi il se déroulera
jusqu'au 2 février sur les courts
couverts du parc sportif philippe
cousteau on en parle avec pascal schultz
bonsoir bonsoir il est le président de
l'association de tennis de la verrière
ce tournant on peut dire que c'est
l'événement phare du club de la saison
d'affaires l'événement phare de notre
saison de notre petit club qui comporte
100 adhérents et on attend le
commencement de ce tournoi qui commence
samedi et on va pouvoir accueillir 140
inscrits cette année 140 inscrits 140
dont 30 femmes
malheureusement ça diminue d'année en
année mais on essaye de promouvoir le
tennis chez les femmes et ça ça ça prend
petit à petit avec un tableau simple
messieurs un tableau simple dames il est
ouvert ce tournoi à tous les licenciés
de tennis de plus de 16 ans qu'est les
profils des joueurs qui seront présents
à partir de samedi
donc là on démarre samedi le profil en
fin de compte masse et des licenciés
on commence par les non classés et puis
on finira par les meilleurs qu'ils le
tournoi est ouvert à 3,6 que depuis
cette année puisqu'il a passé neuf aces
c'est une nouveauté nous demander qui
ont ouvert jusqu'à 5-6 avant et cette
année on le verra 3,6 donc c'est une
bonne chose ça pour pour l'open l'idée
de des joueurs de plus au niveau du cou
qui y participent
ça permet d'augmenter le niveau de voir
des joueurs qui jouent mille de mieux en
mieux et puis ça permet aussi parce
qu'on a les quatre anciens vainqueurs de
tournois qui ne pouvait pas revenir
puisqu'il était limité après il monte en
classement et après ils pouvaient pas
revenir donc cette année nous aurons
quatre anciens vainqueurs qui vont
pouvoir revenir alors pour les non
initiés au tennis ceux qui ne
connaissent pas comment fonctionnent les
classements remporté le tournoi ça
permet de collecter des points
d'améliorer son classement
ça permet de collecter des points pas
forcément
augmenter son classement parce que ça
dépend de toute une saison
mais ça en fait déjà une partie si on
gagne un tournoi on ne gagne au minimum
trois matches des là donc ça permette
comme lectez quand même pas mal de deux
points qui permettent d'augmenter son
classement et donc les matches qui
débuteront samedi et ça se poursuivra
jusqu'au 2 février côté de la sauce du
côté de l'association de l'association
de tennis de la verrière comment ça se
prépare en coulisses ce tournoi donc en
coulisse mais on prépare tout pour
pouvoir accueillir les tous les joueurs
donc les permanents donc à peu près une
dizaine de permanents qui seront là deux
par soir pour aider le juge arbitre pour
accueillir les joueurs de 18 heures
jusqu'à 21h les matchs dernier match
lancé le sueur des matches en soirée la
semaine et toute la journée le week-end
toute la journée le week-end sachant
qu'un match commence à peu près à 18
heures non c'est pas quand il finit donc
il ya trois matches le soir donc un
match clé préviennent 21h peut très bien
commencer à 22h 22h30 et se terminer à
pas d'heure donc une implication
importante des bénévoles pendant ces
trois semaines tout à fait tout à fait
donc tous les bénévoles sont là présents
pour pouvoir accueillir et qui va
libérer les joueurs
une fois qu'ils ont fini leur match
dernière question est-ce que tout est
prêt on est à quelques jours ça débute
samedi cet open de tennis
tout est prêt on va réorganiser la
dernière réunion vendredi la veille du
tournoi pour pouvoir que tout le monde
soit au taquet pour démarrer à 9 heures
samedi matin l'open de tennis de la
verrière du 11 janvier au 2 février
merci parce qu'elle joue ce merci
président de la tlv l'association de
tennis de la verrière deuxième voyage à
présent dans notre machine à remonter le
temps toute cette semaine retour sur les
événements qui ont marqué l'année 2019
les faits marquants et d'avril à juin
c'est avec manon varaldo le mois d'avril
a commencé avec un nouvel adhérent pour
activity saint quentin en yvelines a
rejoint l' agence d'insertion
professionnelle le territoire de saint
quentin
c'est avec le territoire de la vallée de
la seine le territoire willy à la fois
le plus grand nombre de bénéficiaires du
rsa mais aussi où il ya le plus grand
nombre d'entreprises
il ya dynamisme entrepreneurial qui est
très marquée
vd comme a fêté ses cinq ans pour
l'occasion l'institut installé à
versailles-satory organisait une journée
portes ouvertes avec ses 200 employés vd
comme réfléchit à une mobilité du futur
autour des véhicules électriques et
autonome ce drame a ému toute la france
mais aussi le monde entier la cathédrale
notre dame de paris a pris feu lundi 15
avril à 18h50 un symbole fort pour la
communauté catholique
je suis vraiment bouleversé par ça c'est
vraiment un symbole effectivement vous
vous employez le bon mot un symbole qui
est qui et qui est parti qui est parti
en fumée fin qui est et l'émotion que ça
suscite chez moi c'est je crois vraiment
que c'est de la tristesse aussi mais
quelle quel gâchis quoi le département
des yvelines a rendu hommage le 7 mai à
ces soldats du feu 57 d'entre eux ont
reçu une médaille pour avoir combattu
l'incendié de notre dame de paris avec
la première biennale d'architecturé de
paysage la région ile de france ouvrait
ses portes à versailles le 3 mai bapt 3
leds pour découvrir l' architecture à
travers des lieux de patrimoine des
colloques ou encore des expositions
je voulais qu'on donne à voir à tous les
franciliens ce que le grand paris allait
être en 2030
côté sport le championnat national de
quidditch issu de la célèbre saga harry
potter s'est déroulée aux
clayes-sous-bois parmi les équipes les
agent le seul club yvelinois dans cette
discipline après trois ans de travaux le
musée du jouet de poissy a rouvert ses
portes le 11 mai 600 jouets ont été
rassemblés choisi par les 14000 de la
collection du musée inauguré par le
ministre de la culture
franck riester fin mai une grève
mondiale était organisée pour le climat
des rassemblements ont eu lieu dans
plusieurs villes de france à saint
quentin en yvelines c'était une première
300 manifestants étaient présents selon
les organisateurs autre rassemblement le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueilli deux
manches de la coupe du monde de bmx
deux cent soixante concurrents issus de
25 nationalités se sont affrontés
l'événement affiché complet
lutter contre les déserts médicaux une
volonté du département
le 14 juin
ce taux n'est l'inauguration de la
maison médicale d'aubergenville huit
professionnels de santé se partagent les
locaux d'ici 2020 de 20 établissements
de ce type couvriront le territoire
santé toujours les services des urgences
des hôpitaux en grève depuis trois mois
déclenchée notamment suite à une série
d'agressions ils demandent une hausse
des salaires et des effectifs mais aussi
de meilleures conditions de travail
une partie du personnel du centre
hospitalier de mantes-la-jolie étaient
en grève le mois de juin rime avec
baccalauréat pour les lycéens il a
débuté le 17 juin par la traditionnelle
épreuve de philosophie
ils étaient 70 1944 candidat dans les
yvelines pour les plus petits la
préoccupation n'est pas aux révisions
mais au jeu de construction multiples
située à chambourcy les bâtisseurs en
air propose aux enfants et leurs parents
de s'évader dans leur monde imaginaire
un concept unique en france et en europe
sans joindre les pelleteuses sont
entrées en action sur le chantier de
démolition de la piscine de maurepas
malgré plusieurs au cours d'une partie
de l'opposition qui souhaitait une
réhabilitation
c'est bien une déconstruction puis une
reconstruction qui s'annonce est
l'invité politique pour clôturer ce
journal c'est ma belle à des qte bonsoir
comment ça vous avait 49 ans habitant de
guyancourt depuis quinze ans vous allez
conduire aux élections municipales dans
la ville la liste de l'ue dmf vous êtes
le premier candidat connu dans les
yvelines de l'union des démocrates
musulmans français qui prévoit aussi
d'investir des candidats manquent la
ville manque la jolie et les mureaux lui
dmf déjà c'est un mouvement qui est né
en 2012 quelles sont les valeurs que
défend le parti des valeurs de vivre
ensemble de partage de des valeurs
sociales économiques également on essaie
de comment dire de rassembler les
français autour de notre projet est de
de faire en sorte que justement tous
tous puissent être sous la même enseigne
avec une volonté de défendre les
minorités ça c'est un axe france et les
français dans leur majorité bien sûr
mais les minorités en particulier
également qui souvent se sentent rejetés
par par nos politiques on va dire après
après chaque élection
l'udf c'est un parti qui a été accusé
d'être un parti communautaire notamment
en raison de la présence du mot musulman
dans dans le nom du mouvement pur que
répondez-vous à cela à ces accusations
communautariste n est pas du tout à un
parti communautariste loin de là le
terme musulman peut renvoyer vers
plusieurs terminologie plusieurs
définitions
la première la plus connue forcément
c'est la dimension religieuse pour
laquelle nous sommes ni compétents ni
référent nous laissons cela aux
commandes heroes aux organismes
compétents
il faut dire qu'il ya pas dimension
religieuse 25 c'est pour ça que il ya
plusieurs comme je l'expliqué il ya
plusieurs dimensions vous avez une
dimension culturelle
nous ne sommes pas non plus dans cette
catégorie là et vous avez aussi une
dimension je dirais qu'il est plus
démographique et donc c'est cette
population qui se sent stigmatisé
aujourd'hui comme beaucoup d'autres
minorités en france et c'est c'est
symbolique d'un échec social en fait un
achat et d'intégration sociale de notre
gouvernement
tout simplement ou des politiques en
général au niveau de l'échiquier
politique c'est un parti qui situe
plutôt à gauche plutôt à droite plonge
plus haut à gauche surtout à gauche
surtout à gauche
vous êtes d'ailleurs vous un homme de
gauche père d'une famille recomposée
vous êtes ingénieur en
télécommunications et informations et on
précise que c'est votre première
participation à un scrutin tant que en
tant que candidat pourquoi vous avez
décidé de vous lancer justement dans
cette démarche politique
c'est suite à va dire un cheminement g
je suis également président d'une
association humanitaire sur lui en cours
depuis bientôt six ans et aujourd'hui
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya une réelle des
collections on va dire entre entre la
mairie et les aiguilles courtoise et bus
en courtois bien sûr et mais aussi le
tissu social de notre ville tout
simplement
et j'ai voulu justement m'engager parce
que j'estimais qu'il y avait encore
beaucoup de choses à faire
probant ses habitants mais pourquoi avec
l'udf justement aujourd'hui l'udf pour
moi incarne réellement ce ce besoin de
réconciliation des français ce besoin
d'une justice sociale équitable
tout simplement alors qui ont cours
c'est une ville de gauche depuis la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale qui a été
d'abord avec des maires communistes puis
socialiste vous pensez qu'une alternance
est possible alors toujours à gauche
puisque vous vous définissez homme de
gauche mais une alternance est possible
à guyancourt
je pense que oui je pense que oui si on
rappelle le contexte est une ville qui a
connu trois maires en six ans françois
de ligne et qui était maire depuis 2002
et qui a rendu son écharpe en 2016
marie-christine le tarnais qui lui a
succédé en 2019 avant de lui a succédé
en 2016 pardon avant de démissionner en
2019 pour raisons de santé françois
morteau et le nouveau maire est de
guyancourt depuis mai 2010 9 quel regard
vous portez sur le travail qui a été
mené par la mandature actuelle pendant
ces six ans pendant six ans on va dire
que dans l'ensemble c'était assez
satisfaisant bien qu'aujourd'hui comme
je l'expliqué il ya une certaine
déconnexion qui s'est opéré au niveau de
la municipalité avec le reste de la
population
d'où justement le fait qu' aujourd'hui
vous se trouvaient cinq listes c'est une
première à guyancourt
on a eu comme vous l'avez mentionné il
ya quelques instants trois maires
successifs pour un seul mandat
vraiment il ya un certain malaise qui
s'est instaurée à guyancourt du 12e
d'où cette diversité on va dire deux
parties qui émerge aujourd'hui pendant
de votre programme quelques axes forts
une priorité déjà à l'éducation avec une
volonté affichée de lutter contre le
décrochage de scolaires tout à fait le
décrochage scolaire est une est un fléau
qui comment dire qui gangrènent un peu
dans toutes les villes alors je dirais
est malheureusement à l'état actuel dans
l'état actuel des choses il ya très peu
de débouchés ou très peu d'alternatives
pour ses élèves pour ces enfants qui qui
ne se retrouvent plus en fait dans
l'éducation en classique et donc nous
avons un projet justement pour la ville
concernant ce type de préoccupations
c'est notamment d'aider aussi à
l'orientation favoriser l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes est ce que
sur cet aspect il n'y a pas une carte à
jouer avec lui vs cuq est présente aussi
sur le territoire l'université
versailles saint quentin et affective à
intégrer progressivement la grande
université paris saclay tout à fait ça
serait ça serait l'idéal de tisser des
partenariats comme ça aussi bien avec
les universités qu'avec les entreprises
locales
étant donné que guyancourt et quand même
une ville assez riche de par cette
diversité de travail autres axes de
votre programme c'est lutter contre la
congestion routière est ce que c'est une
nécessité quand on sait que à guyancourt
va arriver cette grande ligne cette
grande ligne de métro la ligne 18 qui
est prévue à l'horizon 2030 2030 ça fait
quand même assez long alors on est
encore roger voilà il faut agir avant
parce qu'on ne sait pas à quoi
s'attendre dans cinq ans en terme de
congestion routière
si on doit attendre 2030 dans dix ans
pour pouvoir commencer à réfléchir si on
n'avait pas pris les mesures
nécessaire bien en avant on risque
d'être confronté a quand même pas mal de
problèmes mais ça veut dire qu'il ya des
aménagements à faire en ce sens
certainement certainement y en a
énormément spécialement lorsque vous
partez de chez vous à 8 heures du matin
et que vous arrivez aux commentaires à
rompre un des sangliers à guyancourt
c'est une catastrophe sur l'urbanisme du
en cours est une ville qui a énormément
changé une construction de logements des
réhabilitations vous souhaité implanter
de nouveaux logements sociaux dans la
ville est ce que c'est nécessaire quand
on sait qu'il ya environ 48 % de
logements sociaux et je vais à 40 % de
logements sociaux tout je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous néanmois on se
retrouve quand même dans une
problématique à guyancourt où vous avez
des gens qui ont des demandes de
logement qui n'aboutissent pas tout
simplement qu'ils ont une demande de
logements qui datent de 5 7 10 ans et
qui n'a pas de et qu'il n'y a pas de
solution pour aujourd'hui c'est
davantage les aider voilà sachant
comment cette démarche
ces gens là voient des constructions
sortir de terre d'année en année et ils
ne peuvent pas en être bénéficiaire et
quelques autres axes forts de votre
programme
quelles sont la sécurité la sécurité je
pense que la plupart des candidats nous
avons des points communs en termes de
programme c'est juste les solutions que
l'on va proposer qui différentes
voilà tout à fait donc pour nous
l'éducation est prioritaire nous avons
ensuite la sécurité nous avons également
l'écologie et c'est ce que nous allons
proposer prochainement au but en
courtoisie courtois lors de nos débats
et tout ce programme ces projets que
vous lui portez nécessite forcément un
lien fort avec l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui est ce que les
liens actuels sont satisfaisants est ce
qu'il vous faut les renforcer sinon je
pense qu'il est impératif de les
renforcer aujourd'hui il y a cette
déconnexion entre la population et la
ville
on la retrouve également avec la
communauté d'agglomération malgré ce
qu'on peut nous dire en conseil de ré
ont cassé
dc pâle sur le terrain c'est autre chose
un mot sur votre liste pour terminer ce
qu'elle est totalement constitué vous
êtes encore à la recherche de choristes
nous sommes encore à la recherche de
talents on va dire tous tous différents
on va dire nous sommes ouverts à tout le
monde sans distinction de religion de
condition sociale ou autre vous êtes
français vous voulez vous investir pour
elie dohin courtoisie guyancourt toi
rejoignez donc une place forte de nos
citoyens on voit fleurir des démarches
citoyennes dans tout l'est dans tous les
commerces et les démarches citoyennes
justement quand vous y regarder de plus
près à ce forme justement parce que
jusqu'au niveau 2 au niveau des
politiques en iran s'y retrouve plus
tout simplement et vos prochains rendez
vous avec les clients courtois justement
dans la troisième semaine de janvier
non on n'a pas encore défini de date il
faut qu'on fasse une réservation de ses
relais auprès des services municipaux et
vous en serez informés
merci m avait là des coups que je
rappelle que vous êtes là c est la tête
de liste de l'union des démocrates ce
musulman français à guyancourt pour ces
municipales dans cette ville quatre
autres listes sont en course celle du
maire et divers gauche sortant françois
morton avec lui en cours pour tous
nouvel élan pour du en cours sera
conduite par grégory pape soutenu par la
république en un show livier parler je
sors en lice pour décidons ensemble à
guyancourt une liste participative enfin
rodolphe barry conduire à la candidate à
la candidature ensemble agissons pour
aiguiller en cours voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité dans
un instant première édition du 7 8
culture de cette année 2020 une émission
en grande partie consacré ce soir à la
fête du conte qui a démarré le 15
janvier à saint quentin en yvelines
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]